bonjour mademoiselle voici donc je vous
donne le kit du randonneur vous avez
l'autre vers hop là vous pouvez mettre
autour du cou
c'est plus prudent l'attirail du parfait
randonneur dégustateurs les chaussures
ne sont pas fournis et les rendent
auront le but de faire découvrir les
appellations au travers de la
dégustation des vins des appellations et
en même temps de découvrir les paysages
viticoles mais fiona nos partants ah
ouais c'est parti pour trois heures de
marche à travers les bois les champs et
les vignes à la découverte des terres
argileuses à silex du touraine mêlant le
guide s'appelle bruno et il est l'un des
huit vignerons de l'appellation donc là
c'est nuit charles daney chablais c'est
un cépage blanc donc le tour elle
mélange blanc en général est un
assemblage de chemin ou pinot de la
loire chardonnay et sauvignon
nous sommes sur le plateau 2 1 nous
passons à travers les vignes nous avons
trois arrêts première escale au milieu
des vignes où la vendange 2010 9 et
presque prêtes à être récoltées ici on
goûte le millésime 2018 et le fromage
des voisins un verre d'eau un verre de
vin comme ça
tranquille à la fac mais je n'y habite
net je biello chexbres du bois du vin
avec plus de 30 degrés celsius au soleil
les randonneurs boivent de l'eau et
goûte le vingt deuxième étape à la cave
très apprécié et là il fait frais et on
a eu un guide fabuleux qui nous a tous
expliqués et des gens très très
accueillants et cet incident tout les
vignes du val de loire ce week end de
bourgueil à vouvray en passant par
chinon pour les 400 randonneurs du tour
end mêlant aujourd'hui la prochaine
étape sera rouge avec du boudin noir et
de la bonne humeur